yes this is happened over the weekend
manchester united's star player
christian ronaldo may be one of the
biggest players of all time
loses to everton one nothing oh my god
everton he's like
[Laughter]
that's embarrassing
[Laughter]
yeah so this kid's filming him
oh wait why is he injured why are you
limping bro you got a slight tackle his
legs all [ __ ] up hey you know he's not
real injuries he's filming his injury
why did they put that spray on
smacks a kid's phone shatters it and
bruises the kid's hand bro
i mean how old is he is he really a kid
or is he one of those like british
[ __ ] that don't age yeah he's
like hezbollah yeah i think he's like 15
or something are you sure and apparently
an artist right he's he's an artist oh
come on with dawg i don't know if he's
teased out i don't know if he says that
he's something he's my fan now you
should definitely yeah you should
definitely look into this he's something
yeah his mom posted a picture of the
bruise the bruise is kind of brutal i
couldn't i couldn't find out what i saw
but it was kind of bad oh my god a
bruise like this imagine lebron james
smacked this [ __ ] out some kid oh he got
to get some bread for that i need you to
call me yeah that's my point what a new
phone in a sorry no a new phone in at
least 10 million
what
i'm a retarder
he's going to say i'm autistic now yeah
that's what you gotta say
real talk
he gotta come in there he should say he
got covert from a contact hand-to-hand
contact
ronaldo what's his name ronaldo
cristiano ronaldo says take his cat so
we would have taken his cat first
ronaldinho or ronaldo no ronaldinho is
different okay
that's cristiano cristiano ronaldo
whatever his name is
yeah cristiano ronaldo
is him and then uh then uh ronaldinho is
a difference but the kids should have
did like the players and just like grab
their ankle and be like ah
no he was like yo my bad bro like i was
really mad after the game but uh i'll
bring you out to old trafford to watch
the game anytime you want who wants to
go to old trafford
come on what's old trafford that's where
maine united play that's their home why
why don't they play in manchester they
do play manchester well why do they play
over an old trafford then because that's
the name of the stadium no no no i want
new
old trafford is an area no
isn't it not it's the name of the
stadium no
it's an area it's a stadium
i believe andrew i bet you look up where
he stayed from manchester united
about this if it's an area once again
you've gotten all the soccer [ __ ] bro
you know nothing about soccer
that was the stadium it's a stadium in
the town of old trafford
let's go
to the [ __ ]
it's an area
[Laughter]
i didn't say anything
astoria
midtown i don't know where the next
place get a real name for a stadium
manchester united
dude i'm saying get a real name right
like you don't even got a real name yo
you like manchester city just cut you
out of that [ __ ] real tall just [ __ ] you
bruh what are they called manchester
city it's like city stadium or something
tell them or manchester state
it's got manchester in the name
robotic error
robotic air i mean let's just call it
what it is
if you went off your human intuition
your gut bro you could have never gotten
it wrong yo that's a good point that's
why i love the new york jets that play
in new york bro they play they they do
not play i know they're playing jersey
we don't call them the new york jets we
call them the jets
stop that's a fact nobody's ever calling
the new york jets yeah we just call them
the jets hey
the giants jets and giants giants
do you call them the new york knicks no
call me mix nix i just call them losers
that's all i call brother the word
franchise
news over here okay just like manchester
bro yeah
you know who used to play forever timber
who's that who used to play favorites
which america used to tim
damn
soccer
[Music]
yeah
okay guys for real though
okay because because now that we've
learned
what have we learned what are we even
talking about manchester plays amazing
soccer stuff
manchester plays in manchester
manchester plays at manchester united
old trafford
is a area of manchester is it area
manchester united and also the name of
the stadium no no no no no no no no it
is the name of the stadium no it's not
yeah it is no it's not
i've looked up
what that stadium is registered under oh
really yeah what's it registered look it
up look it up what does that mean
registered under yeah like what the llc
is um
the old trafford stadium llc
okay and what is it
look it up um
you'll see yeah
[Laughter]
you'll see
rolling the dice on this one
[Laughter]
you'll see
what is it there's no answer on google
bro well
robots fail you again don't they mark
robots will fail you again
so is the kid going to suit i don't know
it doesn't seem like it like why
wouldn't he sue
yeah he was
that's insulting that's what christopher
yells also that's part of this is
telling him what to do
no but why would he not sue maybe it's a
different culture out there but like he
was assaulted legit yeah like
it's not just i'm gonna slap the phone
like i'm gonna hit your [ __ ] hand
yeah and in the states that's a felony
because this is over a thousand dollars
oh it's uh uh destruction of uh property
or something like that he's already
received a million dollar offer
they they went to him and said name your
price please quick you think they
started at a million whatever yeah yeah
i couldn't imagine what a [ __ ] idiot
why would he get so angry at a kid
though like
you think maybe he was upset about this
limping sees someone sticking out a
phone and swats it [ __ ] that yo as a kid
but he's used to this since every single
game there's somebody with a kid pretty
crazy in the same 10 days the biggest
footballer
ever you know 425 million instagram
followers really the number one and then
will smith same 10 days slapping
yeah and nascar slapping maybe cristiano
ronaldo's a scientologist
and the phone disrespected him he has
slapped the phone and let it know
you